i got to tell you i mean if if you had
told me before the super bowl
okay if you had told me before the super
bowl that
the uh tambay buccaneers would score 31
and every point that was put on the
board um in
in the end zone would be only by the
free agents brought in along with tom
brady
gronk antonio brown leonard fournette if
you told me that
and then on top of it that the defense
would hold
uh the chiefs to no touchdowns uh this
is what i would have
this is what i would have said what are
you smoking bro give me something okay
there you go
that's what i would have said the man
who gave me that quote uh is joining me
here now on the rich eisen show
bruce arians how are you coach doing
great rich how you doing brother oh
better for talking to you
uh congratulations bruce congratulations
man
it's still it's just sank in about
halfway up the river holding a
lombardi trophy in the shed of tears
saying holy
we did this you know
coach it really is a remarkable
run that your team went on obviously
from week 12 all the way through
to that podium and and it's interesting
see it didn't happen until the boat
parade where it actually sunk in
to you huh yeah it really did i mean i
was going i mean
okay we got to lombardi we're on the
boat everybody's there
fans on both sides and then we hit a
certain spot there was like
fans hanging out buildings and hotels
and top
so i'm like i got to lombardi and i'm
like
even with my bad shoulder i got it over
my head going
all right we we won the damn super bowl
so who was on your boat walk me through
who's on the boat the bruce arians boat
uh it was it was jason like mike
greenberg
john spy tech all their wives um it was
yeah it was uh it was awesome
and uh you know so it was yeah our boat
was
we were had a great time we must play we
are the champions about
20 times uh it was it was hard rock
going on our boat
uh all the way now when on super sunday
did you say
first cross your mind bruce you've been
there done that obviously so you know
anything can
can change where you thought okay this
this i think this is going to happen
tonight
when was that for you not until devon's
interception at the end i mean
you know patrick has come back so many
times he's such a great player and uh
until we intercepted that boss that
there's just not enough time for them to
get it back
and get us and i put that hat on
and all of a sudden i got my first
gatorade bath
uh that actually hit me because the only
other one i ever had was back at temple
but i had brought a banner suit and i
was not gonna let them get me i was
quick back then
they couldn't catch it
and uh but i just sat there and when the
gatorade hit me it was like
i've been waiting for this for like 30
years
and then um so let me let's just spend
just a little more time on
on the game here um and
what todd bowles was able to cook up uh
coach what did you
d did you did you um did you think that
this would be
something that uh would leave with no
touchdowns for this chief's
offense going into the game well i i can
honestly say rich
i knew if we didn't give up any bombs
and that was our whole plan just keep it
in front of us our reds on defense
in green bay and new orleans was
unbelievable so
i knew they were going to have a tough
time scoring in the red zone and if we
just didn't give up anything big
and uh i mean we were fortunate the
whole game plan came together we got the
lead
we could we could play too deep and our
front four just got
after and after patrick and uh you know
it was like the perfect storm for us
and devon white i had him on yesterday
um first time ever spoke to him i didn't
speak to him before the draft
and i haven't had him on the occasion
has not uh
occurred to have him on before yesterday
i i
i wanted to run through a wall i just
love his he seems to you know you got
obviously brady's mentality on offense
and there's some other
no doubt um uh serious hardcore
professional uh mindsets on your team
i love this kid he said that you told
him um
that he was gonna if you're gonna take
him top five if he was still available
and then that then what you said to him
when
he called you when you called him up on
draft night that i told you so
pretty much right that's what you said
to him yeah i mean i mean i love him
he brings so much passion and energy
every single day
yet just to be probably the most
talented linebacker in the league
uh but when you when you package him
with levante david
his experience and his speed uh
it's a lethal lethal combination bruce
aaron's here on the rich eisen show what
did you learn about tom brady this year
bruce
what did you learn from all of being you
know
you know what rich i i've told that he's
just one of the dudes
i mean he's just one of the guys on the
team uh
you you when you when you're far away
you see the glamour you see all the
stuff you see the competitive spirit
but he really is just one of the guys
and
the way he handles our younger players
um helping them out and i'm not just
talking about football like devin
he went through a rough time when he
make all pro tom pulled him aside
said look we got bigger fish to fry than
more pro man and
you're going to get all those on her
someday but we're going to win the super
bowl
and you know uh just that
bringing he could he could tell when a
young guy was down and go figure him out
and go help him off the field is it true
that he texted the entire team
before the super bowl we're gonna win
tomorrow did he do that yes
yes and he gave a hell of a speech uh i
gave my talk and i don't talk long
uh pregame and he he started talking
about being honored
and being remembered and uh our guys
came out of locker room i mean
they were they were ready to roll so he
gave the last word to the team before
going out
on the field yeah i i i gave mine and uh
i think
my then lavonte said something then tom
tom said something and they came out
with
a look in their eye that i knew we were
going to win can you tell me a little
bit more what did tom say to the team
before going out on the field uh about
being remembered you win this game
you'll be remembered for the rest of
your life you'll be honored for the rest
of your life
and uh the honor that comes with winning
the super bowl
you guys have no clue let's go play our
best
and win this thing because what the
rewards are unbelievable bruce arians
here
on the rich eisen show okay um coach
uh i know you uh i've been fortunate to
interview you many times
um and get to know you uh when we're not
uh wearing microphones or in front of
microphones i knew this already carson
palmer
confirmed it as well the other day that
you have no sacred cows
uh there's no sacred cows okay that you
tell it like it is
so um the concept of tom brady's
departure
from the uh boat parade um
how how are you gonna approach tom about
this and and how much crap is tom gonna
receive
for the way that he left the super bowl
parade
bruce arians and you know what rich he
might have he might be onto something i
have never seen avocado
um infused tequila
but i'm sure there's gonna be some bars
with it lined up
all right uh for a long long time and uh
yeah i haven't tried it myself but uh
they might talk me into it
okay yeah i mean i i said this is the
most relatable moment you said he's just
one of the guys
clearly this is uh this is confirmation
of him just being
one of the guys right here oh yeah yeah
i mean all
our our our crew um everybody's on the
same level man
um i mean i love our players and our
coaching staff do you
our front office and the scouts man we
had we had a blast on the river and uh
and well deserved if you can't have one
there uh why not
so uh when you had the trophy on your
boat did you flip it to another boat
yourself too
is that how you no
somebody else had to flip it what do you
think
that you know very rarely is the most
important super bowl toss
uh happening after the game but that's a
pretty uh important piece of tiffany
uh what what's more impressive the toss
of the catch by cameron break
coach which was a catch all the way
because there was a lot of tequila on
that boat
all the way i don't know if you heard
the video of it but his uh brady's
daughter vivi is the one
who's the most uh sensible one on the
boat
here it comes no no no here it comes
you'll hear it
where is dad now
she was the most sensible one on the
whole boat oh there's no doubt on that
boat
and um now that he went out and got him
a boat now that's a sweet boat
that is quite the ride right i mean um
i love boating and that is an awesome
boat well i'll tell you what he's tb12
so now uh here comes more of the
celebration
uh coach let's get into um perhaps the
most
um uh important celebration of all
right here um you're you're gonna hold
the super bowl celebration happy hour
with coach bruce arians
coming up on february 19th a couple
hours
uh cocktails with the aryans we have the
there's the the invite that's up there
for
uh 300 lucky 150 lucky individuals
limited spots each ticket's going to be
300
all going to the arians family
foundation you go to
aryansfamilyfoundation.org this is going
to be on february
19th neat stuff coach looking forward to
what you've got cooked up here yeah man
i can't i'm so happy you're going to be
a big part of this and uh
you know just just to raise some money
for the foundation it's been really
really hard with the pandemic and uh
you know steve webster and jake came up
with a great idea
so happy that you're involved we've got
some great celebrity guests
and just you know friday nights happy
hour yeah i was going to ask you you
know who was the host of the event um
and because you have obviously a very
crucial role
for you right oh yeah of course and
that's only one and only
i appreciate it one and only well i'm
i'm i'm honored to have been asked and
i'll be there
um so what do you what do you what do
you have uh hoping to get cooked up here
just some
some luminary stopping by on the zoom
raise as much money as possible
yeah we got some guys that might sing a
song or two and uh
somebody that might uh might act like me
a lot
and uh so we uh it's uh it's gonna be a
lot of fun
and uh then chris and i will sit back
and answer questions and uh
and have a cocktail or two and just
enjoy the hell out of the night
and that what a what a neat way to you
know pay it forward here
uh to the arians family foundation
because normally you do have an event
uh every year but in covet 19 world uh
aryansfamilyfoundation.org is where you
can go and
get in because uh seating is is limited
um what's going to be your what is your
drink of choice
coach what is that well you know it's
it's whether the sun's up or down
okay let's walk through it then sun up
it's kettle
okay uh sun down this crown all the way
yeah all you need is ice cubes with
either one but uh
crown and ice that's it okay yeah i saw
what you had on kimmel when you were on
kimmel's show earlier this week
yeah that was that was that was one of
the better crowns
yeah i mean and why not to to celebrate
the crown so
now again that you're a few days later
uh coach
what do you have in your brain right now
now that you're able to relax and you've
been around your family
and the the parade is over i i mean
your journey is a long one to this
podium
what what goes through your mind in a
quiet moment
bruce uh how much how really how much i
i enjoyed having my brothers and sisters
but especially my mother
there for a couple days pregame i didn't
get a chance to see him after the game
with all the obligations with the press
and everything
and uh but
i mean it just meant the world to share
all that to have my grandsons
uh at the stadium and waving and uh
it's just win or lose i mean it's all
about family
well and it's also you know as well you
know your
your wife cause you when you were here
bruce uh
on the show okay and you were you were
talking to me i believe it was just
after you left arizona
and you said that you had retired as a
family from coaching
because you had mentioned that your wife
was was kind of through with the
ups and downs of coaching and maybe some
of the health scares
for you and now i'm just wondering if
you wouldn't mind just
getting a little bit personal about what
this sensation is for you now that
you've won it all
you came back and you got that yeah i
mean we actually just got off a plane
back here at the lake
and to be home uh what she's been
through
for the last 50 years is you know our
50th wedding anniversary is june 12th
hopefully cove is over by then and we
can have a party but
i mean what she's been through moving
her 19 times and
getting getting back here
she's enjoyed this process this year as
much as anybody and i wouldn't got back
in coaching that she wasn't
all in and uh she's been all in and
tampa's made it so so special
again i cannot thank the glacier family
enough
for everything they've done for my
family congratulations to you and your
wife to you and your family and again
everyone
um get ready for super bowl celebration
happy hour with coach bruce arians make
sure that you
you get in while the getting is good uh
at the website uh
aryansfamilyfoundation.org and let's
raise as much money as we can for the
arians family foundation coach i
cherish the phone call thank you
appreciate it oh thank you brother let's
help those children let's do that those
children need us
let's do indeed let's do it through the
arians family foundation and i'm honored
you asked me to host it
uh i i said uh that was an i was a quick
yes
you had me at hello hello
thank you brother right back at you
enjoy your downtime that's coach bruce
arians just got to his lake house
calling in here amazing right on the
rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here